bonjour à tous
quand j'ai dû choisir un sujet j'ai été
contacté j'ai beaucoup hésité et puis
j'ai un ami qui m'a qui m'a parlé de
finances et qui m'a dit
aujourd'hui ben c'est simple sur les
places financières il ya plus de traders
ça ça n'existe plus enfin c'était
vraiment de la caricature et il m'a dit
ce sont des machines qui les ont
remplacés et le métier a disparu alors
je pense que s'il ya pas mal de
personnes qui doivent penser comme ça
peut-être même dans cette pièce c'est
peut-être vous posez la question lever
la main si vous pensez que les traits le
métier de trader a grandement disparu et
que dans les métiers de la finance bas
les machines commencent à prendre la
place
lever la main si vous pensez que c'est
le cas
ça fait quand même beaucoup de personnes
je trouve mais ça c'est normal pendant
c'est normal de penser ça et en fait
c'est pour moi une légende urbaine et
j'aimerais bien la déconstruire
aujourd'hui avec vous je serai bien
parler de tout ça pour vous expliquer
que eh bien en fait
il faut être un peu plus nuancé
et que pour moi dans mon sens les
marchés financiers en fait il constitue
vraiment l'ultime exemple d'un
changement de paradigme c'est pas
uniquement une disparition de métier
c'est plus un changement vraiment
d'écosystèmes ou en fait des métiers ont
été remplacés par d'autres métiers et
pas des métiers qui ont été remplacés
par des machines
donc déjà pour commencer qu'est ce que
c'est que le trading
qu'est ce que c'est que le trading le
trading en fait c'est simplement
l'action de faire des achats et des
ventes sur une place boursière pour
faire simple le trading s'est effectué
des transactions sur un marché
maintenant qu'est ce que c'est que le
trading algorithmique
le trading algorithmique c'est un
concept qui a paru il ya quelques
dizaines d'années en fait c'est apparu
en même temps que l'avènement de la
technologie
et c'est en fait une activité de trading
mais qui utilise des algorithmes pour
effectuer des transactions
alors vous me direz qu est-ce que c'est
la différence en fait un trader à
l'époque c'était devant un ordinateur et
ç'a cliqué pour acheter et vendre et la
maintenance et des algorithmes qui font
le travail en fait la différence elle
est subtile mais elle a une énorme en
ait un impact sur le métier c'est que
quand c'était le trader qui cliquaient
sur sur la souris et sur le clavier qui
appuie sur le clavier c'était lui qui
prenait la décision
la maintenance et la machine qu'il
apprend alors attention encore une fois
c'est pas tous les métiers du trading
qui ont été remplacés mais s'attend à ça
tend à le devenir et une immense
majorité des métiers de de ce type là
qui commence à laisser place à la
machine et j'aimerais bien faire un cas
particulier c'est sur ce cas particulier
surtout que je vais beaucoup parler
c'est le trading haute fréquence
qu'est ce que c'est que le trading haute
fréquence en fait c'est un cas
particulier du trading algorithmique
mais qui s'effectue sur une fréquence
extrêmement
haute en fait tout simplement
ça se base sur l'idée suivante c'est que
si on effectue énormément de
transactions et qu'on a une probabilité
supérieure à 50% d'avoir un profit en
fait en moyenne on va être gagnant tout
simplement ça évidemment en enlevant les
frais de transactions etc mais bon ça ça
c'est du détail
je vous donne un exemple si j'effectue
un million de paris sur une journée donc
un pari pour moi c'est j'achète un
produit que juge à un prix bas et je
leur vends un prix que je juge la plus
élevée ce n'est pas que je juge plus
élevé mais qui est plus élevé comme ça
je réalise un profit eh bien imaginez je
fais un million de paris comme ça j'ai
60 % de chances de gagner un centime et
40% de chances d'en perdre un et bien en
moyenne à la fin de la journée j'aurais
2000 euros de profits
c'est bien plus complexe que ça en
réalité mais ça vous donne une idée de
qu'est ce que c'est que le trading haute
fréquence
est alors pour d'apporter une précision
en plus qui rend les choses vraiment
pour faire toucher un peu du doigt à
quel point c'est extraordinaire c'est
que des logiciels haute fréquence
peuvent faire jusqu'à un million de
transactions par jour même plus alors
vous imaginez bien et c'est là que je
veux en venir sans machine
si je met quelqu'un devant un ordinateur
et qui doit appuyez sur entrée un
million de fois ben je donne pas chère
la peau du bouton entrer quoi afin de
tourner je pense qu'il va falloir
changer de claviers et puis je pense que
les décisions seront complètement
hasardeuse en plus de ça et je suis même
pas sûr qu'il arrive à appuyer un
million de fois en 86400 secondes
donc maintenant le mon sujet mais
j'aimerais aborder c'est comment est ce
qu'on a pu en arriver là c'est vrai vous
pourriez me dire mais pourquoi pourquoi
donc faire ça pourquoi utiliser les
machines pourquoi leur laisser prendre
la décision à l'époque les traders c'est
même encore le cas ça existe encore et
évidemment mais un trader qui
apprendrait la décision lui même et puis
qui appuyait sur le bouton pour acheter
et vendre qui passerait son appel etc en
fait c'est la même chose s'y prend les
bonnes décisions je ne vois pas la
différence et ça c'est une question
légitime
pourquoi est ce que vraiment le marché
financier a été transformé par ce que là
c'est radical c'est une transformation
imaginez c'est comme si vous alliez dans
tous les supermarchés et qui en fait
c'est y avait que des agents de
surveillance pour les caisses
automatiques
ccc ce qui est en train de se produire
mais ça s'est produit à une vitesse
folle et enfin j'aborderai la question
légitime aussi que vous devez tous vous
posez c'est est-ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle parce que ça en fait c'est la
question millénaire et je pense qu'il
n'y aura jamais d'autre vraiment de
réponse mais moi je vais essayer de vous
apporter de la nuance est de vous
éclairer sur
manière dont avec laquelle il faut
appréhender ce sujet mais est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour l'économie
la majorité donc des opérations
financières elles sont réalisées à
partir de règles prédéfinies donc par
exemple
j'achète une action et bad et que ça
prend 10 % je revends et dès que ça perd
10% je revends aussi puisque j'ai peur
que ça aille plus bas et que je perde
tout donc ça ce sont typiquement des
algorithmes c'est un algorithme c'est
très facile à coder les informaticiens
savent très bien faire ça y'a pas de
problème la machine peut très bien le
comprendre donc déjà ça vous éclaire un
peu sur le fait que en fait ce que fait
un trader c'est un algorithme donc on
peut très bien le mettre sous forme de
machines n'y a pas de problème
mais en fait ça va beaucoup plus loin
que ça et pour vous expliquer le
pourquoi du comment je prends un exemple
c'est celui d'un spéculateur sur un
marché de légumes de fruits et légumes
comme ça ça parle à tout le monde c'est
pas compliqué c'est pas barbare et est
donc imaginer
quelqu'un qui qui traitent sur le marché
des fruits et légumes et qui se dit ben
voilà cette année je vais traiter de la
tomate ce que je vais faire c'est que la
bomba on est en janvier je sais que la
trop la tomate c'est récolter entre
juillet et septembre est ce que je me
dis c'est que si la récolte est mauvaise
le prix il va monter parce que la tomate
va être plus rares et donc du coup si je
m'arrange avec un agriculteur à l'avance
pour que au moment de la récolte je
puisse acheter de la tomate au prix de
l'année dernière eh ben je réalisera un
profit je l'achète au prix de l'année
dernière je revendrai bas plus cher un
petit peu après quand ce sera alors très
simple
le premier problème que notre
spéculateurs va avoir c'est en fait
qu'est ce qu'il va faire
qu'est ce qui va faire
bah en fait il va regarder des
indicateurs météorologiques il va
vouloir prédire si la récolte va être
bonne ou pas donc il va regarder des
indicateurs comme la température la
météo tous les en fait tous les
indicateurs météo le vent le temps
d'exposition au soleil
les prédictions du changement climatique
la probabilité qu'ils aient du gel en
juin par exemple il veut affiner le plus
possible sa prédiction en utilisant le
plus possible de paramètres il va
construire en fait un système très
complexe
dans lesquelles il ya des corrélations
folle avec une bonne récolte ou une
mauvaise récolte il va vouloir prédire
le mieux possible mais le problème c'est
que vous en convenez suivre 150
indicateurs météorologiques au jour le
jour vérifier ça chaque heure
regardez comment est ce qui fonctionne
entre eux commencent à corréler comment
un loyer mais températures oui mais le
vent il mais c'est extrêmement compliqué
c'est extrêmement complexe même nous en
tant qu'humain qui avons on est quand
même on arrive quand même à apprendre
beaucoup de choses mais si on passe
toute notre vie à étudier ces choses là
je suis même pas certain qu'on soit
capable de faire des bonnes prédictions
en suivant ces choses là bas en fait les
machines peuvent le faire aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on appelle par exemple
l'intelligence artificielle et c'est
typiquement des algorithmes elles vont
prendre elles vont prendre en compte
énormément de dimension plein de
paramètres et au jour le jour et vont
surveiller ça et puis au final elles
arriveront à sortir une prédiction et
puis on va les tester sur le passé pour
voir si elle arrive à faire à faire des
bonnes prédictions et s'il arrive à le
faire sur le passé par exemple est bon
pour aller mettre en production et notre
spéculateurs de marché sur le marché des
fruits et légumes pourrait spéculer sur
la tomate et il sera à l'aise il se dira
mont à ligori qui marche bien sur le
passé peut-être que ça marchera bien sûr
le futur et je fais ce pari
et là c'est là que vous touchez du doigt
quand je parle de ça
pourquoi je vous dis que en fait ce
métier n'a pas disparu exactement en
fait ce qui s'est passé exactement dans
les marchés financiers et ça c'est
extrêmement important de le comprendre
c'est que c'est un changement de monde
c'est à dire que des métiers ont disparu
plus ou moins mais ce sont d'autres
métiers qui les en place est maintenant
dans les marchés financiers vous trouvé
énormément de mathématiciens de
physiciens même fut un temps
d'informaticiens de data centers dont
scientifique de la donner parce que le
fait qu' il y ait du trading haute
fréquence ça génère énormément de
données du coup il ya des scientifiques
de la donne et ces mêmes des ingénieurs
télécoms pourquoi des ingénieurs
télécoms
sa
c'est parce que notre spéculateurs sur
les marchés de fruits et légumes il fait
face à un second problème
là je vous ai donné l'exemple où il est
tout seul il est tout seul il à son
algorithme qui marche plus ou moins et
puis ce pécule seule quoi s'il se sent
puissant il al'avantage parce qu'en fait
c'est un marché sur lesquels c'est que
des gens qui vont acheter sur la place
sur sur au marché du dimanche et uil à
son algorithme qui y perd développer
hyper sophistiqué mais imaginez imaginez
fait l'expérience suivante mentale
imaginer qu'il y en ait des milliers
comme lui qui est tous pensé à ça qu'il
ya un algorithme qui est une machine un
superordinateur très performant très
bien calibrée sur le passé très bien
configuré qui arrive à faire des bonnes
prédictions etc etc donc en fait il ya
beaucoup de concurrence et de la
concurrence de son niveau
est bien là il a un problème c'est que
en fait
l'offre elle est limitée
il va vouloir envoyer en fait là son
ordinateur lui dit tiens je prédis à 90%
que ça va être une mauvaise récolte à
bâle a vite l'ordinateur il va envoyer
un ordre par exemple il va envoyer à un
agriculteur bah tiens je veux signer un
contrat avec toi comme quoi tu vas me
livrer 100 kg de tomates en juillet pour
le prix de l'année dernière et
l'agriculteur lui il est content il a
pas besoin d'aller au marché en juillet
donc il lui dit ok ça marche pas de
problème on fait ça mais sauf qu'il ya
des milliers comme lui qui vont envoyer
ça cet agriculteur donc il faut qu'il
soit le premier et 6 et des ailes des
algorithmes des ordinateurs qui font ça
c'est extrêmement rapide donc il faut
qu'ils aient l'ordinateur le plus
performant possible il faut qu'ils aient
toute une infrastructure derrière qu'il
utilise par exemple la vitesse de la
lumière est pas la fibre optique pour
aller jusqu'à donc il faut qu'ils
utilisent des ans des antennes radio et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'avec
l'avènement du trading haute fréquence
il ya des choses complètement
extraordinaires qui sont passées c'est
qu'il ya des firmes de trading qui ont
payé des ingénieurs télécoms et qui ont
loué des antennes radio partout en
europe les antennes radio et des
terrains avec ses antennes radio là il
est loué tous les mois des centaines de
milliers de dollars pour envoyer bas
tout simplement pour gagner une
milliseconde sur les concurrents voire
plus ou moins qu une milliseconde
quelques nano secondes sur le concurrent
et bat acheté le premier au prix qu'ils
veulent des choses complètement
surréaliste
et donc revenons au sujet maintenant
en fait pourquoi les machines elles se
sont imposées dans le milieu financier
déjà alors le premier point c'est pour
être plus rapide que ses concurrents et
avoir le meilleur prix
le deuxième point c'est pour avoir des
ordres d'achat et de vente donc des
ordres d'achat c'est tout simplement lui
dire je veux acheter ou je veux vendre
vu que c'est basé sur des règles
prédéfinies et pas ce sont des
algorithmes par définition ça se prête
très bien à la construction de machines
et aussi pour aller dans la finesse
d'intuition vous pouvez vous dire une
machine ça va pas d'émotions et ça c'est
particulièrement important dans la
finance parce que ça on lui dit surtout
on le dit les machines remplacent les
humains oui ouais mais c'est parce
qu'elles n'ont pas d'émotions c'est trop
bien oui mais en finance c'est
particulièrement important justement
parce que ça arrive tous les jours qu'un
trader ne suivent pas la règle c'était
prédéfinis parce qu'il se dit je m'étais
dit que je revendrai si ça prenait 10 %
mais
c'est un prix 10 % ça peut-être prendre
encore dix si je vais attendre
et puis la machine va pas dire sa
machine va pas se dire vous avez un les
nouveaux pas dire
ouais mais mon maître concepteurs qui
m'a construite à l'informaticien l'afld
franchement j'ai discuté avec mon pote
le macbook air il m'a dit je le sens
bien là j'ai du flair je sens que ça va
monter encore je pense que je vais
attendre c'est une bonne idée vraiment
c'est super super idée alors oui mais
sauf que cinq minutes après en fait ils
avaient tort c est redescendue et il a
perdu son profit il aurait pu avoir
raison mais il n'a pas suivi sa règle
donc bah ça c'est hyper intéressant et
ensuite il ya aussi le fait que ben une
machine vous pouvez l'empêcher d'avoir
des conflits d'intérêts si elle est
programmée pour ne pas en avoir si elle
est programmée pour suivre la régulation
à la lettre eh ben la suivre et puis si
elle a su passer un bug informatique et
l'informaticien qui l'a conçu il peut
s'en occuper facilement maintenant
est-ce que ça ça démontre et je pense
pas d'accord avec ça est-ce que ça
démontre que les machines sont un fake
c'est super et qu' il faut que les
traders soient remplacés par des
machines du coup c'est ce que c'est
c'est incroyable ça pas d'émotions ça va
à la vitesse de la lumière est ce que
c'est vraiment le monde qu'il faut pour
la finance
le 6 mai 2010 il y a eu ce qu'on appelle
un flash crash voir krach éclair
en fait ce qui s'est passé un flash
crash c'est lorsque il ya une baisse
brutale du prix complètement
imprévisible pour nous humains une
baisse brutale du prix tellement
violente qu'en fait est bien quelques
temps après
ça revient un petit peu à l' équilibre à
la moyenne alors ça revient pas à la
valeur forcément la valeur précédente
mais en fait ça fait un trou et ça
remonte imaginez c'est comme si le prix
de la tomate pendant l'espace de 30
minutes sur un marché ça passait de 2
euros 50 le kilo à 10 centimes de ko ça
remonte à 2,40
exceptionnel
en fait c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
le 6 mai 2010 en fait ce qui s'est passé
et ça bah vous imaginez bien que ce qui
est derrière ces les algorithmes c'est à
cause d'eux les méchants en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un
il ya une institution financière un
agent qui a voulu vendre un montant
astronomique en volume d'un produit
d'accord ce produit la représenter c'est
le s&p 500 il représente enfin l'indicé
s p 500 il représente la santé
économique des plus grandes
capitalisations boursières aux états
unis et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que il a envoyé ce don qui l'a dit voilà
je vendre énormément de ce produit
quelques milliards est en fait bancaire
est la réaction d'un humain simple on
voit ça on dit bon bain le prix risque
de baisser parce que il va vouloir
vendre beaucoup les prix vont
s'effondrer
est ce que je peux faire c'est je vais
baisser un petit peu mon prix et puis
les autres humains ils vont baisser
leurs prix pour acheter je parle pour
lui acheter parce que ils veulent pas
ils savent que le prix va baisser ils se
disent bah je vais pas acheter trop je
vais baisser un taux puisque j'anticipe
que ça va baisser le prix bon je vais
acheter un jeu lui acheter ce qui veut
vendre à un prix bas vous prenez
mais en fait les algorithmes ils ont
réagi comme ça mais à l'échelle de la
milliseconde donc en fait en quelques
secondes ce qui s'est passé c'est que ça
ait fait un effet boule de neige les
algorithmes se sont dit bon bah je vais
lui acheter a appris un peu plus bas
puis l'algorithme numéro 2 s'est dit
ouais mais là le goût 1 il a il veut
acheter à ce prix là je vais acheter un
prix encore plus bas et caetera et
caetera et en fait ça fait écrouler le
prix et il a perdu 10% en quelques
minutes
et en fête bat donc on peut se dire que
les algorithmes
se sont emballés alors la solution est
ce qu'il faut couper le disjoncteur ans
car je dis ça parce qu'il ya une
anecdote assez drôle quand ça s'est
passé on paraît que dans certaines
firmes de trading haute fréquence il ya
des traders haute fréquence qui se sont
jetés sur les multiprises pour tout
débrancher parce qu'il était en panique
complète il se disait mais ils sont en
train de devenir fou ces algorithmes en
fait les algorithmes n'avait pas été
entraîné sur ce genre de choses il avait
entraîné sur des sur des marchés où les
volumes ne sont pas des liens et l'a eu
un volume délirant qui arrivait le mec a
voulu vendre 2 milliards ou je ne sais
combien d'un produit et l'algorithme a
complètement déluré et ils se sont
emballées
maintenant
en fait pourquoi cette crise elle est
dangereuse on pourrait me dire oui mais
c'est pas très dangereux en fait ça perd
10% puis après quelques minutes après ça
revient un peu c'est pas dangereux dans
le fond bon dans un certain sens je peux
comprendre cette réponse mais dans le
sens purement économique c'est très
dangereux pourquoi parce que et je vais
revenir pour finir sur mon exemple du
marché de légumes après
pour bien comprendre le ce procédé mais
pourquoi c'est dangereux c'est parce
qu'en fait qu'est ce que c'est au final
une action le prix d'une action qu'est
ce que ça reflète ça reflète la santé
économique d'une entreprise qu'est ce
que c'est un indice comme le cac40 par
exemple ça reflète la santé économique
du pays ça reflète même la santé
économique des grandes capitalisations
de ce pays et donc du pays
si ça s'écroule en général c'est qu'il
ya un événement grave qui s'est déroulée
par exemple qu vide
et de crise de 2008 aussi mais là c'est
pas vraiment le cas en fait là il ya ça
reflète plus la santé économique du pays
si ce sont les algorithmes qui dirige
pour reprendre le mot anglais qui drive
la direction du prix d'un produit
imaginé bas des fruits et légumes ça va
plus ça reflète du tout le la santé
économique de cette chose là et c'est ça
qui est dangereux c'est que
ce produit là qui représentait sa pour
les états unis et bien pendant quelques
minutes ça a été juste le résultat
d'algorithmes qui se sont complètement
emballé maintenant pour revenir sur un
marché de légumes
en fait
je n'ai pas forcément prendre l'exemple
que j'avais écrit là mais un qui parlera
plus c'est imaginer un marché avec 500
vendeurs de légumes 500 langues vendeurs
de tomates et en fait ils ont une borne
à l'entrée une borne par laquelle
rentrer les gens et sortent les gens et
leur algorithme en fait donc ils ont
tous un algorithme dans leurs marchés
qui évalue le nombre de personnes qui
rentrent et le nombre de personnes qui
sortent hockey est en fait en fonction
de ça s'ils voient qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui rentrent ils vont faire monter
les prix parce qu'ils savent que ça va
se vendre et s'ils voient qu'il ya
personne qui entre et qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sortent ils vont faire
baisser les prix
imaginez ça donc en fait en règle
générale toute l'année ça va représenter
l'offre et la demande tout va bien se
passer et puis tout à coup on sait pas
pourquoi mais d'un coup il ya une foule
immense qui rentrent dans le marché d'un
coup ça se fait en quelques minutes ils
n'étaient pas prêts il ya une foule
immense qui entre le 1er mai le premier
stand qui à l'entrée l'algorithmie avoir
ça il va paniquer et vas-y rebond balle
et j'ai monté le prix up plus un euro kg
et puis l'algorithme numéro 2 qui
surveille ce qui se passe il voit la
foule et en plus il voit son collègue à
côté augmenté le président j'ai encore
l'augmenter c'est parce que toute façon
c'est la tendance ça va continuer à
augmenter et etc etc et ça ça fait un
effet boule de neige sur les 500 stands
et au final vous retrouvez avec un prix
à 45 euros le kilo et ça ça se produit
en quelques minutes puisque la foule en
fait elle a à peine entré que tous les
algorithmes et réagissent comme ça à
l'échelle de la milliseconde et
au final le prix de la tomate ne reflète
absolument pas la
qualité de la récolte d'une part mais
aussi les la demande des restaurateurs
etc etc
pour terminer j'aimerais aussi parlé
d'un danger de ces algues au rythme là
qui est complètement en lien avec
l'intervention précédente c'est en fait
la manipulation des prix parce qu'à
l'échelle haute fréquence
c'est extrêmement complexe de on peut
pas voir les choses ne pas observer à
l'échelle de laives de la milliseconde
près on peut pas observer
ce qui se passe et ben en fait il ya
beaucoup de trading haute fréquence qui
utilisent justement si le fait que ce
soit à haute fréquence pour manipuler
les prix et donc les prix sont encore
moins représentative de l'économie
et ça c'est particulièrement visible sur
le bitcoin sur les crypto monnaie en
général et c'est pour ça que toute
l'action qui est en train de se dérouler
là c'est que les régulateurs et la
réglementation va se tourner vers la
gestion de tous ces problèmes
et donc pour conclure
non c'est pas possible on peut pas
laisser les machines gérer l'économie on
peut pas laisser les machines tout faire
tout seul il faut absolument qu'ils
aient des humains qu'ils soient derrière
et c'est pour ça qu'il n'ya pas
disparition de métier à proprement
parler c'est simplement un changement de
paradigme les nouveaux métiers qui se
créent et donc les sciences surtout
qu'ils deviennent omniprésente dans ce
milieu je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]